Now I'd like to ask you a couple of programming questions.
These are completely optional, but if you did the programming in the unit,
you might want to try these out.
During the unit, you wrote a function that can compute the mean of a set of data.
I'd like to now ask you to write something a little different.
Write a function, mean, that can take a known mean of existing data--
in this case I called it current mean--
a count of the amount of data I have, and a new value
and tell me what the mean is now.
And so to call my mean function I'll just type in mean(currentmean,currentcount,new)
And we can see it gives me the correct answer of 9.0.
Here is the function, mean, that you'll fill in.
It takes the old mean which we called current mean below,
the number of observations--n--and the new value to be added--x.
Insert your code right below the comment. Have fun.